Talk about HMMs just in general,
and then we'll move onto vision.
In general, HMMs are generative
models of time series,
with some notion of a hidden state, that
is they can talk about the probability
of generating a particular output.
The forward-backward algorithms, those
recursive ones allow you for computing
over the states and you can also use
that computing to train up your models.
And I will say that HMMs were their
big win was in originally in speech
recognition dealing with low level
auditory features and using that to
recover phonemes and then phonemes into
parts of words and things like that.
And then in Computer Vision, although I
will say there's a whole new area these
days called conditional random fields,
which is really better as I mentioned.
If you've got a long sequence and
you want to do segmentation,
conditional random fields are a slightly
more complicated version.
Actually, they're
significantly more complicated
graphical models of
representing time series.
And it tends to do better than HMMs for
the actual segmentation.
But from the notion of a generative
model of saying, was it an A, or a B, or
a C HMMs are still used extensively.